hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast high resolution outbreak
tracing and resistant detection using
whole genome sequencing in the case of
the Mycobacterium tuberculosis outbreak
presented by winning Ritter Berg she's a
senior scientist micro genomics a
hydrogen molecular diagnostics
I am Marjorie Torres of lab reads and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by hydrogen
molecular diagnostics for more
information about our sponsors please
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
just click on the green Q&A button
located on the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen she will be following up with
your questions via email also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hear in
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Winnie little bird I will now turn the
presentation over to her
so welcome everyone to this session I
want recite to you how we have used
whole genome sequencing for
investigating an outbreak of
Mycobacterium tuberculosis and for
detecting antimicrobial resistance using
tools of cryogen microbial genomics
crows suite so I will start by giving
you a brief introduction to
Mycobacterium tuberculosis before moving
on to showing you the case study that we
have chosen and finally I will sent to
you their results on our analysis on
outbreak tracing and detecting
antimicrobial resistance so tuberculosis
is one of the deadliest diseases
worldwide one third of the world's
population has been estimated to be
infected with Mycobacterium tuberculosis
and according to the World Health
Organization and the CDC ten point four
million people became sick with TB and
there were 1.8 million TB related deaths
in 2015 so there are two types of
clinical manifestations of tuberculosis
pulmonary TB affecting the lungs and
extra pulmonary TB affecting other
organs not everyone in fact that with CP
become sick TB can remain latent for a
lifetime without causing disease whereas
in others especially in people with a
weakened immune system TB disease will
develop in either cases treatment is
initiated and antimicrobial resistance
is a major concern so it was estimated
that nearly half a million people and I
developed multi drug-resistant TB in
2015 so water droplet systems game TB is
defined as resistance
so at least it's an asset and rifampicin
and extensive drug persistent in CD is
further resistance to a fluoroquinolone
and one of the injectable second lines
antibiotics such as amicus in kanamycin
or cream icing so my compactor on
tuberculosis has evolved into seven
major images that are strongly
associated with geographical regions
strains are highly clonal there's very
little evidence for the transfer and
recombination of genes and consequently
their nucleotide sequences are very
similar the 16s rRNA sequences do not
differ between the members of the
Mycobacterium tuberculosis complex as
they just a very little recombination
the main mechanisms of the antimicrobial
resistance is not mobile elements with
resistance genes there are other
acquisition the mutations affecting the
binding target and drug target
interactions so TV present a number of
challenges and in order to control
spreads in particularly of the multi and
the extensive drug resistant TV
surveillance is absolutely so
additionally knowledge about the
assistance mechanisms present in this
bacterium is it's really important for
correct and effective treatment the
classical methods for investigating
pathogen outbreaks include contact
investigation which is based on patient
interviews phenotypic methods such as
saira tracking and antimicrobial
susceptibility testing antimicrobial
susceptibility testing of micro bacteria
can be very challenging and requires
good and consistent laboratory practices
because of the clonal nature
of mycobacteria the accumulation of
mutation as the outbreak progresses can
be used for EVD illogical practices so
there are so more molecular genotyping
methods available for micro bacteria
that all target small specific parts of
the genome in the case study that that
I'm going to present to you in a minute
they were using spoiler typing and a
micro bacterium tuberculosis specific
variable number of tandem repeats
genotyping more recent methods include
called genome LST where almost 3000 oh
sorry in the genome are analyzed and
genome-wide comparisons of variant
positions so the advantage of genome
comparisons is that snips are
distributed throughout the genome and
there's very low reverse mutation rate
so I won't lean on sequence analysis
provide by far the greatest resolution
in outbreak investigations and may
precisely distinguish single isolates
which is especially useful for very
complex outbreak situations so a further
advantage for genome sequencing is the
simultaneous detection of antimicrobial
resistance mechanisms present in the
bacterium so there is really the
potential to capture the entire spectrum
I've noticed mutations associated with
persistence the primary challenges in
using whole genome sequencing for
outbreak investigations is sensitive and
accurate detection of variants to
provide maximum resolution for
transmission analysis and for resistance
detection our linking at the second
mutations to antimicrobial resistance
which requires access to a comb
database and finally evaluating novel
mutations not listed in publicly
available databases so I know many of
you are probably familiar with this but
I won't just briefly introduce
cryogen microbial genomics pro suite so
cryogen microbial genomics pros we built
upon the CNC genomics workbench and
contains the microbial genomics module
the meta-gene mark plug-in and the cnc
genome finishing module so our solution
is it's the all-inclusive holiday
version of bioinformatics software
microbial genomics and it supports
analysis in the fields of genomics
transcriptomics
epigenomics molecular biology
metagenomics and pathogen typing so data
metadata and the sauce can be linked in
the workbench and the solution will
contain statistical tools and a range of
interactive graphical visualizations and
metadata so our solution is fully
customizable which means that we
collaborate with external partners to
provide plug-ins for cosmos an ID mr.
jean-marc and glass to go so the last
thing I want to highlight is that our
solution is scalable to meet any sample
look good it can be run either locally
or on the genomic server which ensures
flexibility in with regards to a number
of samples and compute resources so we
know we have a comprehensive tool box
allowing specialized analysis of the
whole genome sequencing data and for the
new user some of these tools may appear
hidden and therefore we would like to
demonstrate some of these using a very
recent case of the micro bacterium today
rose's outbreak earlier this year Phoebe
and coworkers published the study
describing the investigation of a
molecular cluster of multidrug-resistant
TB across Austria Germany and Romania so
the reason this study caught our
attention was that it very well displays
the common challenges of tracing an
outbreak and evaluating the
antimicrobial resistance patterns which
would really allow us to put our
software to the tests so I will now take
you through the outline of the outbreak
so in March 2014 the Austrian national
reference lab detected a cluster of five
multi drug-resistant TB sharing as
protocol type and the entire balance so
an investigation was initiated to
determine if transmission had occurred
within Austria patients 1 2 & 3 were all
diagnosed between 2010 and 12 they
originated from the same city in Romania
that had moved to two different cities
in Austria patients 4 & 5 were diagnosed
in during 20 that seemed they were both
alone in Austria and we're living in the
same city as patients 1 & 2 they had no
prior history of migration or
international travel so the
investigation also revealed that patient
3 had a sister also diagnosed with
multidrug-resistant TB and she was
living in Germany so this finding
prompted the Austrian authorities to
contact the National reference
laboratory in Germany in early April
2014 the German national reference lab
had to take its three isolettes
multidrug-resistant CV and they're also
with the vntr genotype a which was the
same type as the Austrian isolates now
on three patients were diagnosed in 2011
question six which was the pay the
sister of person three and mission seven
dogs originated from the same city in
Romania and patient eight was born in
West Africa diagnosed with extra
extrapulmonary TV with a non
drug-resistant strain so because five
patients were now recorded to originate
from the same city in Romania the
Romanian national TV contact point was
informed so as there had been no
systematic genotyping of TV isolates in
Romania all five multidrug-resistant TV
pilots that were ever detected in that
particular region in Romania was sent to
Austria for analysis so these five
patients were diagnosed between 2004 and
14 isolated from patient 10 and 11 were
of the be in geography inside a the
isolate from patient mine was the NCR
genotype b and the ice electronic
patient 12 and 13 were the NCR genotype
C so all five patients were born and
still living in Romania at the time of
the investigation here I just want to
show you an overview of the 13 patients
included in the study as you can see
five patients live were living in
Austria three patients were living in
Germany and five patients were living
in Romania you can also see that poor
patient had a previous diagnosis of TB
because bacteria it walls throughout the
progression of an outbreak we can
perform whole genome our comparisons of
mutations and obtain information isolate
clustering at very high resolution so
what we have done is to take variants on
a genome-wide scale and subject these
varying positions to solo genetic
analysis so the results are visualized
as a snip tree is playing the
relationship between isolates and the
difference in variant positions
data analysis prior to a snip clustering
and you include data QC mapping reads to
reference and detecting variance all of
these steps are pre-configured in one of
our ready to use workflows and outputs a
list of detected variance for each
isolate so the workflow is
pre-configured with different settings
to get you started easily but all
parameters can be adjusted and also to
meet your specific needs and use cases
so this particular analysis we have
chosen to exclude variants that were
detected in genes known to be involved
in antimicrobial resistance in
Mycobacterium tuberculosis using the
published data our snip tree is based on
673 variant positions near we have
chosen a radio representation of the
dendrogram and we are shown three layers
of metadata being the patient ID which
is shown in in red roman numerals the
country of birth and the country of
residence so as you can see Austria as
life cycle do German isolettes are
colored red and Romanian isolates shown
in gray
so because data and metadata have been
linked it is very simple to select and
display different types of metadata for
example to make a clear representation
of results so in this next figure
we have overlaid the pentagram with
additional information so we can now
also see the isolation date in gray the
vntr genotype which is marked in yellow
and the number of snips applauding
branches those are in black from this
snip tree we can see that isolates
clustering three groups so the top class
that contain isolates from patients all
originating from the same city in
Romania these were both of the entire
genotype C and originates from our
patients 12 and 13 so both of these
patients were still living in Romanian
at the time of the investigation so the
second cluster can say in isolated from
patients that are all originated from
the same city in Romania but that has
that they are living in three different
countries so among these patients
transmission likely occurred before
migrating patients 3 & 6 assistance and
likely have a common source of
transmission as indicated by their
dividend neurological link their
isolates differed by Smith 12 step 7
so walking our colleagues did a
retrospective study of TV outbreaks and
found that epidemiological linkage was
consistent with isolates differing by
one to five snips
whereas isolates differing by more than
12 snips was consistent with the absence
of
pity me illogical link our results here
therefore indicate that the common
source of transmission for the two
sisters and possibly also additional
intermediate links were missing from the
investigation the third cluster contains
isolates from patients to four five and
ten which are free of the austrian
upgrade isolates three isolates from
Austria are separated by just one to
four snips suggesting two transmissions
with in Austria being from patient to
the patient for and from patient to
patient five so from this analysis it's
evident that compared to traditional
genotyping whole genome sequencing
provides a much higher resolution in
outbreak analysis and it may
additionally provide information on the
sequence of transmission events so a
further advantage of whole genome
sequencing for pathogen investigations
is the simultaneous detection of
antimicrobial resistance mechanisms so
the workbench contains their own
different variant detection tools
for this study we used the low frequency
variant detection zone that is optimized
for finding variants in mixed
populations where some variants may
occur at a low frequency the detected
variants were matched against database
of known resistance variants the
resistance database were used to contain
nearly 1,500 different variants
distributed in 31 low side and
controlling assistance towards 15 anti
TB drugs the database was based on the
publicly available set of reference
variants published by Cole and
co-workers in 2015
so the database of coal includes high
confidence variants from CP dream and
movie and also variants listed in
complications of until a 2015 some some
of this we added additional variants
described by me Otto at all which was
published in 2014 and there was
published by a llama Dow in 2017 so
setting up your own database of
persistence variants in the workbench is
quite straightforward all you need to do
is to store your list variants and any
other information you wish to display in
a comma-separated file and import this
into the workbench we found a 123
variants causing resistance 75 of these
variants were described in the original
study while 48 of them were new so the
table on the right shows the detected
variants the low-side they were found in
and they predicted antimicrobial
resistance the column on the far right
displays the additional protected
variants from our study table on the
Left shows the concordance of detected
variants and the antimicrobial
susceptibility test results now overall
we found like the original authors a
high congruence between genotypic and
phenotypic resistance since the
phenotypic assays confirmed the validity
of 30 of the new the newly discovered
variants we consider these to be true
positives so under this assumption the
optimized variant detection pattern
shown here increases the positive
predictive value from 63% in the
original study to 90
to further explore and qualify the
additional variants detected we search
for 3d models of proteins involved in
antimicrobial resistance our tool that
it's called link variance to 3d protein
structure we all take a list of variants
and search against the protein database
for models with sufficient homology the
children a wants visualization amino
acid alterations on 3d models as a way
of evaluating the effect of variance on
target interactions of protein function
one of the variants we detected was in
the DNA gyrase so clinic iris is
involved in super cording of DNA where
it binds DNA and introduces
double-stranded breaks no DNA gyrase
is the target for the fluoroquinolones
which bind the enzyme DNA complex
mutation at the target region will also
the target structure and thereby the
binding affinity for the truck in this
figure we see the DNA carries binding
DNA and with moxifloxacin linked to the
complex to the bottom left we see the
reference model with alanine at position
90 shown in blue and on the bottom right
there is instead a valine which is shown
in green at this position in the binding
site which likely will affect drug
binding so this isolate was indeed
resistant as measured by antimicrobial
susceptibility testing another variant
we have taken a closer look at is a
serene - asparagine substitution in the
binding
channel of the RNA polymerase so RNA
polymerase is that the target clearly
for license which will bind inside the
DNA RNA channel and thereby physically
blocking elongation resistance arises
from a minor acid alterations in the
binding site which decrease the affinity
for the drug in this model we see the
RNA polymerase with every fantasy in
bound in the active site or the binding
channel the once among is shown on the
bottom left in blue and the variant
position with the asparagine
substitution is shown on the bottom
right in in green again we find that
this alteration of the binding channel
changes a drug target interaction and
the isolate becomes resistant to what
the fantasy so we have found that
sensitive parentage section reveals more
mutations with likely causal effects and
that 3d structures can be used to assess
the impact of mutations on drug target
interactions here I just wanted to show
you some additional variants from the
case study that we also found 3d models
for using using our tool ok so to sum up
with this study we have shown how you
can use tools in carriage and microbial
genomics close we'd - for high
resolution outbreak tracing and by
analyzing whole genome sequencing data
our pre-configured workflows for data QC
mapping and variant detection allow you
to get started easily and are optimized
variant detector and track tools for
database comparison
unable are user-friendly detection of
antimicrobial resistance causing
variants our George 4th
visualization can assist you in
qualifying previously undescribed loans
so with this I will finish and thank you
for your attention
Thank You Ritter bird for that
informative presentation if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click on the send button she will be
following up with your questions via
email I would like to once again thank
dr. thang when you read a book for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab leads and hydrogen molecular
diagnostics for making today's
educational web cats possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through December 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcements with your colleagues
who may have missed today its live event
that's all for now we thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon goodbye